good evening I am poppy pooty-poo and
you are watching piu news the most
respected news source
back at it again with amazing quality
feels good to be back man now let's just
jump into it
PewDiePie did a New Jersey can you
believe this PewDiePie did an oopsie
what there's definitely not been any
shortage of calling PewDiePie races this
past couple of weeks there's now a
petition PT pie-faces of petition
calling for his removal from YouTube due
to white supremacist platform Oh frickin
not a petition I might as well delete my
Chandler right here and right now I
might as well start finding a new job
because petitions are the most effective
way to make a change in the whole world
I mean it's not like article 13 got five
million signatures to stop and he did
nothing okay so let's check out this
petition remove white supremacist
content from YouTube yeah I agree I
think that's good I think it looks bad
on everyone if there is white
supremacist content on the platform and
it could possibly just need to another
ad pocalypse so I will actually have to
sign this petition and uh it's literally
just calling to ban me from the website
and nothing else
oh okay sure that will stop it we need
to ban pewdiepie from YouTube that will
stop all the bad things it's literally
just calling me too bad me and nothing
else I'm sure a lot of people just read
these headline stop normalizing or stop
remove white supremacist and be like
I'll sign night sure sure I'll sign that
just by glancing over the points that
they made against me it's so blatantly
misrepresenting and missing forming
people a lot of these points are just
flat-out lies as well context who needs
that unimportant I don't care
why would I need to link sources to any
of the claims that defames a person no I
mean honestly like it's surprising how
changed our org is even letting this
up cuz there's no nothing to back up any
of the claims but let's just go through
it Peter pies in the past used
Ensler twice in two separate videos and
has hired people to say the n-word what
when have I hired people that implies
I've hired multiple people to say the
what are you talking about I can't even
defend myself
I don't know what they are talking about
why would I do that I used the n-word
twice I did it in the live stream okay
it slipped up it was incredibly
irresponsible foolish and stupid of me
to do that and people know about this
I've acknowledged this wrongdoing and I
moved away from it I think it's been
almost two years now but apparently I've
done it in two separate videos and hired
people that's what I did remember that
remember next point he has promoted
videos that contain Adolf Hitler
speeches and anti-semitic cartoons The
Wall Street Journal article about me had
a Hitler speech in it is that what their
reference is that what the referencing
Disney has a famous anti-semitic cartoon
or at least that contains Adolf Hitler
type of propaganda is that what the
referencing Wall Street Journal and
Disney just context matter I clearly he
doesn't he paid any advance at Fiverr to
hold up signs to say death to all Jews
did you know about this has anyone heard
about this did he know Peter pie did
this has anyone ever told you this has
every single media news media article in
the past three years that mentions my
name not mentioned this enough already I
don't think so
another thing that is never mentioned is
that I also wrote to subscribe to
keemstar as well it was so obviously me
trying to come up with the most horrific
sentence I could think of like the worst
thing I could get to pay people to do on
this website this fiber because people
were literally doing anything and it was
proving a point of that and I was
shocked by the results as well it wasn't
like yeah awesome we did it
it was shocking and I thought just that
in itself was interesting but clearly I
stepped too far
I've definitely paid the consequences
and I've learned from that mistake but I
guess we're just gonna keep hearing it
for the past 60 years he
form the Nazi Heil in one of his videos
where show it please show it cuz I don't
think I've done it I've hold up my arm
as a way to prove a point that people
wanted me to be a Nazi so badly but
they'll use anything against me and you
just proven that point yourself thank
you very much
it's such a broken record at this point
I'll hearing all these points like yeah
we've heard that a million times he used
images of famous african-americans neil
degrasse tyson barack obama captioned
with the wrong names oh my god how could
he do this confirmed white supremacist
everyone we do this with everyone wine
or black no one cares it's just so
stupid what does it mean it means
nothing
he made a clip of a man dressed as Jesus
holding a sign stating Hitler did
absolutely nothing wrong I did not do
this this is a false information that
has just been constantly told by people
and no one checks up on it I never paid
him to hold up that sign that was
someone else there's no source I can't
even like dispute it but I remember that
showing up a few days later and I'm like
I didn't do that look this is what I
told him hi this juices I want to say
subscribe to my favorite channel on
YouTube jacksepticeye - I love
jacksepticeye - that's what I told him
to write this is just false I never did
this he makes rape jokes
he makes rape jokes yes six years ago
you're implying that I do it now and the
joke was that this monster was gonna
rape me in this horror game like yeah
extremely childish stupid humor I don't
do that now like why bring it up I said
it's a constant thing on my channel in
his face swapping video he repeatedly
uses an image actress less of a Leslie
Jones to represent Harambee there were a
gorilla killed in the Cincinnati Zoo
last year it seems like they're more
sympathetic about the gorillas than
Leslie Jones
the famous wobbling video was an AI that
face what different things the AI did
this I had no control in it next time
next time I'll be sure to control the AI
I'll do my best I'll do my very best the
thing is like as laughable as these
points are a lot of people are obviously
taking it seriously it's accumulated
76,000 signatures and if you don't know
anything about me and you don't know
anything to challenge these
then obviously it paints a really bad
picture of me that just isn't true or at
least accurate or anywhere near accurate
I would even argue then further on in
the comments they even admit themselves
saying like even if Peter Piper's act
his comment sections are still a
cesspool of white supremacist activities
and commentaries that's a pretty bold
statement I really enjoy this part
because it's like you've argued this
point that I'm a white supremacist that
need to be stopped or at least a
normalization of it that's the argument
here but all the sudden it's like oh
well even if the comments section that's
right the comment section is the problem
the comment section on my channel the
cesspool I mean I agree that it's a
cesspool but not of white supremacist
commentary let's just look at my comment
section let's just check out it's a
cesspool of not - commentary let's just
look at it okay I mean this could be
Nazi stuff I don't know there's a bunch
of Russian comments - series more like
teary rash haha
that's good send them to the range I
think beautifier wants to live it there
like if you have a problem with my
comment section by all means feel free
to come feel free to criticise my
comment section but don't use the
listing of all these things as some sort
of shield for your point don't attack me
with all these inflammatory claims
within lives with no context - then just
go well the comments section is bad it's
so weak it's so measly it's so tiring
this someone pointed out that this
petition is so inaccurate that they even
used - they even used to list a
satirical article about me as as a claim
that I was a white supremacist saying
that I dressed up in an entire Klansmen
robe while streaming so they actually
believe this Jesus Christ there's a
satirical website that did this they
wrote Peter pie accidentally puts on an
entire KKK uniform in the middle of a
game stream hey listen it was an epic
game in Roman I could not help myself it
happens to the best of us this is
clearly just a Photoshop and a joke it's
a satirical website but they list it as
it as an actual claim that I'm
normalizing white supremacist like Jesus
Christ it is laughable but also it's
like people do believe it so it's kind
of sad at the same time
next news that's right everybody there's
no shortage of PewDiePie is a racism
this week
Wil Wheaton attack speed by calling him
a racist piece of a get Wil Wheaton for
those who don't know is a child actress
he was a Star Trek in some other movies
and then he sort of became popular for
being a nerd doing board games and all
that kind of stuff and then he sort of
dabble into this really strange politics
I don't really know what's up with Wil
Wheaton but apparently he posted this on
Facebook saying hi Facebook on one hand
I'm heartened to discover that you know
similar so little about me your
algorithms seem to think that I want to
follow a racist piece of [ __ ] a bigot
on the other hand f you for coming for
recommending and providing a platform
for this racist piece [ __ ] bigot
Facebook provides a platform for a race
of Peter Sagan I'm not even own face but
you dumb schmuck this is a this is a
fan-made group ah well we didn't want to
whack my fan group Oh
so anyone who wants to or feels a need
to defend this guy's words in action as
just being jokes please ask one of your
non-white friends if they think it's
funny when someone uses racist language
of racist tropes I bet you well I have
more non-white friends than you okay but
I thought I was a racist bigot now
you're saying that they're jokes and
making it about how people feel about
Joe if you want to criticize me feel
free to do that again or anything that
I've done but this is such a straw man
argument saying ask a non-white what
they feel about its videos if it's just
a joke there's in place that all my con
is just filled with racial jokes and
slurs it's like no obviously not
that's not the case maybe you could add
a compilation of all they're edgy racist
joke that I've done and to prove some
sort of point like oh look yeah well he
might be not be a giant racist but he's
sure made a lot of jokes like yeah I
have what five thousand videos I don't
even know how many videos I have I'm
pretty sure you can make it you can
prove any point what you can prove
whatever point in the world just by
going through this library you can make
me look whatever way then there were
just a few people defending me in the
comments saying like
Judah's donated more to saying like
maybe looking to the guy a bit more
pretty reasonably claimed dude has
donated more to even just India this
year then maybe you have your whole ride
never mind record-breaking charities the
pie this the fact that he makes crazy
amount less than billionaires and then
will Wheaton hits up with that you know
who else donates crazy amount of money
to people who need it people who aren't
raises it so you do will is that what
you're saying or are you a racist
now I never list the the charity work
we've done in this channel because I
think it's very self loving itself
gratifying and but now that I'm being so
frequently accused of being white
nationalist and racist into constantly
having this list of the bad things that
it's been a paired about me in the media
constantly reinforced I feel like I
should at least bring up that if I was a
racist then why
and even then even if my channel was
racist or my comments were racist or my
audience was racist then why would we
raise $600,000 to build wells in Africa
we raised three hundred forty two
thousand toward saving the children
which helps children all across the
world we waste 1.3 million for the
charity read which fights against AIDS
stoping aids all across the world I
think we raise even more I don't know
exact amount because we also did the
Apple red campaign as well through to
birch simulator which I know was a
pretty significant amount of money and
also two hundred what was a two hundred
fifty thousand towards helping kids in
India I get a better education know
doing charity work does not resolve your
shortcomings or wrongdoings
that's not what anyone is saying people
are just pointing out how constantly
having all these negative fittings
listed without acknowledging any of the
positive is gonna paint a bad picture of
anyone and if just for the sake of just
being ridiculously clear at least in my
opinion
anyone who's racist anyone who's white
nationalist that's not what I'm about
and that's not what this channel has
ever been about it's so crazy to me how
it's even still a topic of discussion do
people really need an enemy that bad
that they need to force it upon me it's
like they wanted me to be an enemy so
badly to just bruised their own morale
moral virtue oh well this successful guy
on YouTube well he's actually just a
racist it's like people can't handle the
fact that I'm successful that's the kind
of a straw man argument but still it it
feels like it it feels like a very
spiteful reaction to what I do in this
channel it's almost getting to the
conspiracy level at this point where
like he played a video game with a guy
that had like a mocking avatar so he
must be a Nazi oh well he gave a shout
out to this one channel that had Nazi
imagery in it out of 30 channels so he
must be a Nazi or at least he was
secretly be a Nazi
that's right secret Nazi everyone
finally I just wanted to finish up with
I I read this comment on a virtue
article a friend of mine sent it to me I
know birch article comments big hikes
but I think it summarized things pretty
well and why some people are so heated
about defending me I had not watched a
single video until the verge began
publishing multiple articles about him I
was initially under the impression I
thought this is interesting because this
person is clearly not a fan of my videos
I was initially under the impression
that his videos would turn out similar
to the horrific I liked its Jonas show
however after watching a few videos I
found them to be less sensational than
described in Barron's article it's
incredibly obvious to anyone with a
brain that these interjections aren't
supporting racism and are instead of
taking cracks at Vox media for labeling
him as a racist when I look back on the
past evidence against him it honestly
said more about the poor journalism
surrounding the situation than it did of
his Bennett did his behavior for example
he recommended an anime reviewers
channel along with other channels
because he liked one of their anime
reviews the channel happened to have bro
white supremacy videos buried in his
history was that really a secret plan to
subscribe kids to Nazi ideals obviously
not a lot of people do think that it
seemed like an obvious and
understandable oversight no one with a
life goes through every single video of
a channel before recommending it well
people are saying well he should have
been more responsible but they always
follow it up that's just a
counter-argument to their initial point
well he's a Nazi well not really oh well
he should be more responsible that's not
the argument you're making that was my
point the other accusation against him
regarding fiber comes off as a big
mistake on his
but I also understand why PDP felt it
was a good way to highlight his point
it's point being that people on fire
will go to extreme lengths to provide a
service even if it means acting
immorally in response to these issues
that you should an apology the leader
the content something you have to twist
tech companies arm to get yet the issue
seems to arise every time his channel is
listed in article I'm probably a good
example of how frequently it's mentioned
because I have no interest in YouTube
culture but checked it out because it
was mentioned so often I wondered how
someone so support supposedly raises and
carefree could generate so many
subscribers as it turns out the articles
were deceptive and sensationalist to my
disappointment that's it for this week's
pew news hopefully we can talk about
something more interesting than hey guys
I'm not a racist I swear but that's it
for this week's hopefully you know this
video will probably have some tabs if
you want to support the channel I highly
recommend it this very epic merch is
available right now on represent icon 90
million club merch let's get it thank
you guys for supporting the channel I
see you guys next time
[Music]
what super simulators becoming relevant
no no don't leave
no please sponsor eagle please do
something
yes yeah this game is still relevant God
dear me